the images of Tyree Nichols a young
black man being beaten to death by
police a day after that video released
people in Memphis still trying to grasp
what they witnessed one man told me he
was shocked by the police violence one
police officer was holding Tyree while
the other one was swinging through like
it looked like like I said it looked
like the same from a movie the way he
was punching through his face and then
he turned around and he did it the other
way then he just he's being held and
he's about to fall and they lift him
back up to take more legs in one part of
the video Nichols is in pain none of the
police officers or paramedics appeared
to provide help that left Ron Simmons
angry it was the constant beating
and then you had the fireman that was
just out there you were supposed to help
he was laying the man was Landing to die
for no one did their job
you beat him to death you beat that that
man that innocent young boy here in
Memphis there are still some people that
have yet to watch the video but even for
many of them the beating death of Tyree
Nichols has left them deeply affected I
intend on watching it at some point I
think but I I this past day or two I've
been sort of bracing myself for it
it's unacceptable I I really really hope
that Justice is served and that people
understand
that this sort of thing is not a free
incident it doesn't happen rarely this
is
America at this point we we got to do
better
Tyree Nichols is now dead and the
residents of this city where it happened
now seeing his death up close
and asking why
Gabriel ozando Al Jazeera Memphis